こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
[音楽]
僕
去年のサウナオブザイヤー2021受賞し
てるんですってぐらいサウナ好きなんです
よ
知ってました結構サウナ好きでもう時間が
あればサウナ行ったりしてるぐらいサウナ
大好きなんですけれども今回そんなので
あるドッキリをしようと思いますその名も
サウナ出たらいきなり
ラーメンドッキリ
意味が分かりません発音してる僕が意味が
分かりませんどういうことかと端的に説明
しますと僕今から
北海道の札幌である
札幌コレクションという
ファッションショーがあるんですよ全国的
に見てもかなり大きい規模の賞があって
いろんなYouTuberさんとかモデル
とか芸能人俳優さん呼ばれておりまして
その中で私はじめしゃちょーも呼ばれて
いるんですけれども
非常にありがたいことに初めて何が
ステージしませんかと言われて僕そんな
ファッションショーで何かできるような
ことがないのでじゃあサウナ出たら
いきなりラーメンドッキリとかどうでしょ
うって言ったら通りました
適当に言ったら通りましたでもやっぱり
サウナも結局おしゃれなんですよこういう
サウンドハットとかサウナ出た時のポンと
玉最近おしゃれなのたくさんあります
ラーメンとは関係ないですけどもそこを
無理やりこじつけたらどうなるのかとお客
さんの雰囲気も僕気になっておりますと
いうわけで今回の企画ターゲット相馬
トランジスタさんです彼もサウナ好きなん
で
相馬さんには別でサウナの番組の収録が
あるということで北海道
札幌まで来てもらいますそれにあの僕とか
とこう出演するっていう感じでサウンド
番組が続いていくんですけどもいろんな
さやのこう番組で回っていくうちにとある
極秘サウナに行ってみましょうみたいな
感じでちょっと目隠ししてあるサウナに
行ってもらいますであの札幌コレクション
のラーメンの会場に特設でサウナ作って
いただきましたねありがとうございます
なんて無茶なことを特設サイト作ってある
ので目隠したのはサウナ入って温かくなっ
てそろそろ出ましょうかって世話の開けた
瞬間rawayお客様大量のラーメン
モデルさん女優さんアイドルとかたくさん
ラーメン果たしてターゲットはどういう
反応するのかそして会場の雰囲気はどう
なってしまうのか
ちょっと怖いです意味が分からないので僕
自身もけど意味が分かんないことこそやっ
てみますでは北海道行ってきます
[音楽]
よろしくお願いしますか
楽しめそうっていうか
好きだからね
特にどれが一番この楽しみというかいやー
シークレットサウンドなら何かっていうの
もねマジで聞かされてないもんねマジで
ずっとサウナブームで作られてってるんで
まあでも今もあるもんね
[音楽]
[笑い]
何してんですか何してんですかじゃない
はーい
[音楽]
いい
感じですやりましたね
えーなんで真似してんのもう
目指したがりみたいなね
[音楽]
はいというわけで今サウンド番組を途中で
抜け出して僕だけ札幌コレクションに戻る
という動きです僕以外の皆さんはこんな後
サウナ番組普通に2軒目行ってて3軒目の
時に僕と合流してでその3軒目に行くなっ
ていうのが
シークレットサウナ
札幌コレクションサラダでございます先に
現場に向かいます
他のステージもあるのでそこに出てその後
最後札幌コレクションサラダに相馬さんを
入れたいと思います
お疲れ様です
頑張ってありがとうございます
ホテルとか言ってないですかはい気をつけ
てくださいねわかりましたそうですね
[音楽]
[拍手]
着いたかな
着きました
[音楽]
ほうがいいあ
ユニコーン脱いだ方がいいですかね
これ脱いだ方がいいですよね
これ脱いだ方がいいっすよね
できますか
これ脱ぎます
[音楽]
入ります
すごい
えー
[音楽]
と取れちゃいます
取ってくださいあとですか
取る
取ってくださいはいおー
すげぇなにここどこ
すげーなんか響く目隠しも取っていい
らしいです目隠しちゃっていいのない
すげえもうじゃいきますね1234まで
いきますね123でいきましょういき
ましょう
せーの123
[拍手]
こんなサウナなんだこれ
景色がすごいってさっき整い場の景色ね
整う場所のあの
外気がそうです
すごいらしいですよ結構かかりそうなのか
俺多分行ってきます
整ういきましょう
早くない行きましょう
[音楽]
[拍手]
ラーメンです歩きましょう
[音楽]
[拍手]
入っててサウナ出たと思ったらラー
メイドッキリでした
おかしいの本当に意味わかんないもん本当
にだってもう俺も意味わかんなかったし見
てる人も意味わかんなそうなったもんね
はじめしゃちょーしか笑ってないの僕も艦
これと出たことあるんですけどあんな静か
なんですよ
今やサウナもおしゃれなんで
ファッションですはいそれは見てください
関係なくね
協力して
そういうことなんですよ結構その脳みそが
今までにない国境だと思うんですけど
でしょうかはいというわけであの裏で番組
やってたんですけども
本当にあの番組ということで今回の
ドッキリの裏側は&サウナさんの
YouTubeチャンネルで見れますので
そちら皆さん是非見てみてください
というわけで私はじめしゃちょーなんと
札幌コレクションに出演することになって
いるんですけれどもどうしてもやりたい
ことが一つありまして何かと言いますと
札幌コレクションでサウナを出たら
ランエーだったドッキリをちょっと仕掛け
たいと思ってるんですけども現実的に不可
のあんな大きなラーメンでサウナを準備し
て出てドッキリするのは結構厳しいみたい
な感じが今出ていたんですけどもなんと皆
さんとある企業さんがですね僕のこの企画
にちょっと協力していただけそうな雰囲気
がありそうでなさそうなのでちょっと今
から私お願いしに行きたいと思います
果たして実現可能となるかどうか行ってき
ます
[音楽]
初めまして
始め社長と申しますサウナをさっき
盛り上げていらっしゃる
クレドインターナショナルの白井社長でお
間違いないですはいちょっと非常に申し訳
にプリンですけれどもお願い事がござい
まして僕もちょっとサウナを盛り上げた
いって言ってる気持ちがあるんですけれど
も
札幌コレクションという
ファッションの
祭典みたいなのあるんですけれどももし
可能でしたらそこでサウナ設置して
いただけることとかできないです
竿が盛り上げたいですから
わかりましたいいんですかはい
任せてください一緒にサウナ業界に
盛り上げましょうかもう是非よろしくお
願いしますありがとうございます行けそう
です
ちょうど今夢叶えるプロジェクトという
若者に夢を与える大きな
イベントをやりますので
ぜひそれ
逆に協力してもらいたいのでですね今日
アンバサダーの市川美織さんが来てます
フレッシュレモンのちょっと説明して
もらっていいですかねー
来年の3月27に帝国ホテルで最終審査が
あるんですけどそちらの方でですね
是非ともはじめさんに
審査員長を務めていただけないかなという
お願いで今日は来ました
審査委員長これも白石町
是非お願いします
ぜひやらせてくださいありがとうござい
ます
ぜひそのライン夢をたくさん叶え
てらっしゃる始めさんにいただければ
嬉しいです今日も社長のおかげで夢一個
叶うんでありがとうございます是非お
願いします
次の仕事があります
忙しいです
是非よろしくお願いしますありがとう
ございましたよろしくお願いします
[音楽]
やっぱ小島さんが好きだと思ってたので
はいでもそれスタートラインは入れている
のは嬉しいです
けども
悔しいです大先輩なのでそうじゃないです
かありがとう
ございます
そうですね私でもサウナ初心者の方なので
やっとったれるようになってきます
水準まであのスタート地点にやっと立てた
かなぐらいでそしてですねちょっと
早速で申し訳ないんですけどもう一つ
ちょっとお願いがありますはいまずですね
もうキー曲でサウンドアングルの
発掘番組を行う予定なんですよそこでもし
よかったら私がですねその番組の
MCをちょっと自分のさせていただくと
いうことでそこにですねはじめさんの
審査員として
皆さん多分アイドルも大好きだと思うので
好きなサウナとアイドルを掛け合わせた
そのプロジェクトも
ぜひご協力お願いできたらいいなと思うん
ですけどどうですか
そうですね
間違いたいと思いますやりましょう
即決ちょっとね初めましてなのでそんなに
たくさんですね
色々ご協力をお願いいた
します
結構頼まれたなってちょっと部分が結構
すごい方にすごいお願いします
自分の中で
[音楽]
撮ってもう一つだけできればいいんです
けどこの後お食事とかって大丈夫です